[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
sick this week at the round table of dim
lighting you'll have to be listening to
me speak like this and you know what did
I bring my tissues I didn't my friend
Josh ok can you can somebody help please
get the tissues there's a tissue box in
our office which I've been carrying
around with myself all day be careful
with the dogs you let the dogs out don't
let the dogs out this week at the round
table of dim lighting we are going to
get rets tissues and hopefully minimize
him talking because the more provides me
talking yeah cuz the more you talk the
more I can tell you're sick and the more
you're spewing stuff into my radio I
have been purposely directing it away
from you all day I'm currently speaking
over the right side of my mouth so it
all goes to one side oh can you face
that way are you cool with that not sure
I'm protecting nursing to this story but
also face that way like you Kiko look at
that got my tissue box there today we're
gonna update you and each other on the
spring break adventures we have we're
two spring breakers yeah
we're not over 40 we still go on spring
break with our children right so yeah we
had a full week off that we have not
fully downloaded to each other I mean
it's in from calendar time it's the
distant past but in relational time it's
like yesterday yeah it's been it's
yesterday brother a week and a half or
so we do want to let you know that your
boys have been nominated for a couple of
webbie's for your favorite or at least
the podcast you're listening to right
now ear biscuits yes we are a webby
nominee in podcasts best host which i
think is me but but you know i think
that's me oh really
yeah it actually said in parentheses the
shorter one so you can go to a funnier
one if you want to vote for me or link
for best host so we're best they don't
have a best ho that's immunity catechol
you shouldn't make us compete against
each other we're competing we get other
people know the whole idea is that
people compete against that we compete
against each other to generate more
votes for us collectively because what
we're not telling everybody is that a
vote for me is a vote for us and a vote
for you as a vote for us about twice you
can't vote because there's an audience
choice and we want you to choose us vote
dot webby awards calm through April 18th
2019 but that was just one of the
nominations link the other nomination
was just best podcast in the Comedy
category
yeah very honored Thank You Webb B's for
the nomination listen we don't have much
control over the judges choices but we
can encourage you to vote we are part of
the Academy vote dot webby awards calm
and we will be voting for ourselves look
only for ear biscuits and a GMM is also
nominee yet can you vote for yourself
GMM is nominated for a variety series
comedy and I think is that all we got we
got an honor GMM host we got an
honorable man Joe so there's not good
we're not my hosts of GMM to make
nominee but we are good enough to be an
honoree and all all we do is go on
vacations and come back and talk about I
mean and then you call it comedy that's
right it's the new comedy oh you know
what that's you think it's better than
no that's not what you call it filming I
only started to don't tell you don't
touch my we're gonna have to dissent it
but you just actually well sanitized it
you gave me and us a quarter an idea for
what the future of this podcast could be
let's just be travel buddies and just
talk about our travels yeah okay can can
we go separate because if we go together
there's nothing to talk about you're
right yeah yeah I see where you're going
with that can we be estranged travel we
go
we're not travel buddies we're travel
correspondence you need to raise your
mic a little bit I think Smosh has been
using your mic stand and you're hunting
you're not supposed to tell people that
Smosh records their podcast in here
you're gonna make them sick yeah that's
my goal like Smosh sick
that's not strategic for us I'm just
gonna be honest so I went back to London
for spring break
and we took I had this idea in Jani
where he may be I think maybe it was the
end of last year I had this idea went
because Lily our oldest daughter our
oldest child is turning 16 well she just
did March 31st she turned 16 and I was
thinking wouldn't it be cool to just
take her on a vacation just us me
Christy and her so it's not a family
vacation this is like a dedicated time
to just make it special for her at such
a special point in life I mean they call
it sweet 16 for a reason well question
mark so I would like to explore at some
point how sweet it was there were a
couple of acute sour points which I will
get into exciting and it's that I I
don't know I'm still processing it allow
me to process with you so I will give
some London recommendations on my second
trip there and in just a number of weeks
and I will use those and I of course
went to a different part of the world
closer I went to Colorado and skied and
had some harrowing experiences there
wouldn't say I almost died at least you
had heroin in Vail manat as I didn't
come as close to death as you know
sometimes you never know how close you
got to death I mean maybe I just missed
death but I I embarrassed myself in a
big way a little at times again we will
know when we die and watch the footage
back right how close you came to death I
don't know if I'll be there though
travel estrange travel buddies we're not
gonna die this thing doesn't do it
that's the name of the strange travel
buddies is the name of the other podcast
I do want to tell you about another
travel thing that happened to me just
two days ago so do it for those of you
who read the book of mythicality
or came to the tour mythicality you know
the story that I tell about my wife's
grandmother Gaga and her integral and
sort of very funny role in our
relationship of emailing back and forth
well you should tell trunk
version basically she had an email
address back in the 90s when I was
getting to know Jesse and Jesse did not
so I literally emailed her grandmother
who would then print out the emails and
then send them to Jesse because you were
in box I was in a different place and I
tell that story in in the book and with
Callie and on the tour but anyway Gaga
at the age of 94 passed away last week
well I'm a little a little more than a
week ago I was sad to hear that and we
went home for a rate woman a memorial
service and I already knew that she was
an incredible woman I knew that she was
and like I told you that she was like
strangely great like unusually unusual
you know like she had all you know she
kind of fit the typical older southern
lady in a certain number of ways but she
also was just in the shop she would say
like sobbing she dropped her arm
laughs yeah yeah it was like that old
southern belle kind of thing but like
something is up in the air you know
that's you literally talk like that and
she not joking yeah this old Raleigh
accent but as we told stories about her
we just all these things came back to
was that the ceremony like a
storytelling yeah it was literally we
just all got together at her daughter's
house and my mother-in-law and we just
told stories about her and she we all
wore white she's like I don't want y'all
to wear black I want you to wear white
because this is a celebration I lived 94
years
and so anyway it was there's lots of
laughs lots of funny stories about got
lots of Tears at the same time but
anyway I had to make a very quick trip
to North Carolina for the weekend took
the red-eye on Friday night there's
actually an airport in New Bern yeah
which is not too far from where your
wife grew up down east and that's a lot
closer to because we was actually at my
in-laws beach house is where we had the
ceremony sounds like well this is a
quick trip I'm gonna fly directly to New
Bern in and rent a car and go down to
the beach house and I was gonna fly on
front of flew on Friday night we should
we filmed all day yeah yeah yeah so I
yeah we
we were shooting GMM and some other
things on Friday and so we went pretty
late so I took that red-eye which
incidentally was one of the red eyes
where I was hoping that it was gonna I
was gonna have a little bit more room
but I basically just set in an upright
position and tried to sleep which was
not fun it's not fun for a big man to
have to do that tell that to a horse
believe it's one of the reasons that I
got sick because I didn't get a lot of
sleep and I was already getting sick
anyway
beautiful ceremony on Saturday and then
Sunday we're gonna go back and of course
we have to go to the New Bern Airport
then you take the flight from New Bern
to Charlotte North Carolina like a
Puddle Jumper situation I mean it wasn't
yeah it was a small a small plane bigger
than I anticipated but still pretty
small you know one one row of seats and
then two rows yeah one column of seats
and then two columns of seats on each
side of plane and so we get to the
numeron airport which incidentally is
like two gates and there there are like
a strip mall it's like you're pulling
into a retirement home
oh that's been better that's what the
airport is like like literally the
rental car drop-off is just a parking
lot and it's for all the companies and
then when you go inside the every no
matter what the rental car company is
you deal with the Alamo person so like
there's a sign on the enterprise thing
that says we're out please talk to Alamo
so like they got one employee like
handling all the real cars there's
rocking chairs in the airport which
incidentally there's rocking chairs in
the Charlotte Airport but it's much more
quaint in the New Bern Airport which I
think it sounds like Coastal Carolina
Regional Airport are you sure you
weren't flying out of a Cracker Barrel
it was as much like a Cracker Barrel as
an airport can be okay so we I hope to
be successful enough to park my private
plane at cracker rails it's so small
that you don't just get there and then
go through security you get there and
you sit outside and then right before
your plane takes off they're like okay
everybody go through security then you
go through security and this basically
get on the plane like that's how small
it is so lock and I get there
I got there like an hour before the
flight which is very late for me
typically you know what I'm saying like
am I like a 1.5 to 2 hours ahead of time
but I knew that deal with an anxious
wreck and I get there an hour early and
then I realized that the flight has been
delayed by 30 minutes which is going to
give us about 30 minutes to make our
connection like from the time the doors
we touch down in Charlotte we got about
30 minutes before they shut the door to
the other so I'm a little anxious
anything could go wrong here sitting
there waiting and then the flight gets
delayed no we get onto the fall to the
runway and the pilot says I unfortunate
news we've been given a weather delay
for we're gonna take off in
approximately 30 minutes that's not so
basically my entire buffer yeah it's
gone so first thing I just made in that
rocking chair first thing I do because I
had become basically totally dependent
on people helping me do things at this
point is I text Jenna oh that's my
assistant our sister oh gosh and I'm
like Jenna here's a situation actually
called her I call her I was like okay we
were supposed to have a buffer we're not
gonna have a buffer and just I just
needed a shoulder to cry on I need you
to the phone I need you to get me on the
next flight I talked to the woman at the
gate and Newbern preemptively and she
was like well the next flight is
completely full you could do standby or
you can fly out in the morning and I'm
just thinking about the fact that I
don't want to be there and I'm with
Locke by the way so Locke and I flew
together because Jessie and Shepard
we're staying a couple days extra locks
got to get back to school I got to get
back to work we got things happening we
got things scheduled we got meetings etc
important enough to have an assistant
and so she was like okay I'll get on the
phone with the reference actually the
representative is supposed to call me
back in 50 minutes because that's what
when she called the number they were
like to get a call back 50 minutes from
now so she did that and that's about how
long the flight takes so we touched down
but mathematically speaking and I'd
already like I'd talk to the pilots I'd
gone up to the two pilots because there
were everybody sitting them with each
other and I start talking with them with
let you guys know you could
you were sitting with the pilot of
pilots were sitting waiting to get on
the plane I'm not waiting to get on the
plane and I was like hey guys how
confident are you in this in this
getting you know getting to Charlotte
they're like younger than me and so and
they were like well you know it'd
probably be a 1 hour total from you know
closing the doors to opening the doors
getting off the next plane and they were
like where you got to get I got a really
tight connection to LAX and they were
like okay we'll do whatever we can to
get there as fast as we like I don't
know how what kind of control they have
I thought it was all autopilot anyway
what do you think they might say you
know what we'll just take you to Los
Angeles yeah I've seen you on the
internet will reroute the plane you're
nominated for a Webby hey do you have an
assistant that was what I was all right
we're going straight to LA hoping they
would secretly recognize me in making
accommodations but that didn't happen so
anyway I was freaking out as you might
imagine and then we we our flight out of
Charlotte was at 5:45 the plane lands
now you've been told they closed the
doors 10 minutes before departure 5:35
the doors were closed we landed we touch
down on the runway at 5:25 it took seven
minutes for them to you got three
minutes to get there but not only that
because the plane is so small we had to
valet our bags so we couldn't just get
off the plane we they had to put the
plane had to put the bags with the tags
underneath the gate check the back okay
so how much time did you have when you
got your backs one minute okay we had
one minute we got our bags at 5:34 I'm
texting Jenna she's like the gate 8 the
woman says that you're not gonna make it
she's talked to the gate they're not
holding they're not holding it for you
that's what Jenna's saying that the
American Airlines woman is saying to her
so she's like I've already got you
booked I think I think they didn't know
who you were and they've already got you
booked on the next flight so first of
all I looked at a map of the Charlotte
Airport and I was it all the way at the
end of terminal D and I had to go REI to
go all the way down II kinda borne this
thing all the way down Ian's back up D
and I'm like looking at the thing I'm
like okay maybe I can make this I was
thinking maybe I can make this in five
minutes when I had one minute I was
already sick anyway
Locke and I pick up our carry-on we're
literally carrying our carry-on and we
both have backpacks we start running
locks a young man he's 15 he's in shape
he kind of gets ahead of me pretty quick
pretty quickly I'm running as fast as I
possibly can without hurting myself
through the Charlotte Airport Wow saying
excuse me excuse me excuse me excuse me
excuse me you know it's being as polite
as possible still a good southern boy I
would have just resorted to a beep then
they just think you're backing up they
think excuse the cart when you do that
and then they look for a car just fly
into the airport eventually I had to
stop and gather myself oh I mean it was
that crazy just take a breather hands on
the knees multiple times so in the end I
stopped for three times and we get all
the way to the gate and I see a bunch of
people lined up I'm like this is
potentially really good news and then
the guy is he just run out this dude is
like they changed it to six o'clock guys
no worries
really they moved it back 15 minutes so
they had already boarded boarded my
group but so I'm like sweating profusely
like I've got a hoodie on that I've worn
and ran in and anyway I think that sent
me even further into sickness because I
just completely exerted myself that's
the most I've worked out in probably a
decade and it was just a run across the
Charlotte Airport and you know I could
have strolled because it was I had 15
minutes instead of one I would have said
you know what I'd rather not worry about
this and I wouldn't have done you know I
mean I'm not rubbing it in I'm just
telling you I would have not done
anything I would have been like we'll
I'll get there when I get there well but
ironically I would have gotten inside of
ten you would have missed the flight
that's your opinion I would have missed
the flight if they had I would have
missed in a huge fight I would have just
got I wouldn't have ran I would have got
on the plane without you yeah I would
probably wonder and probably would have
ran but I'd have been very angry about
it and then I would have been proven
right when we got there but what Yaak
say was he mad no he was thought he was
excited it was an adventure
well he's not 41 he didn't almost pull
something or die he could you grab the
trashcan so I've gone to throw my snot
Laden tissues onto the floor and then
Jenna did all this work for nothing
now Keiko's doing this way look at you
man look at you man anyway get your own
Kleenex can't get your own trash and if
you need the directions from gate e38 to
gate d-10 Charlotte just hit me up on
twitter that's at Rhett MC I bet you
smelled horrible no I smell good
actually did my sweat tends to generate
good good odors gosh listen at you man
listen at listen I'm gonna share my
experience and then hear about yours uh
but first we got to promote some stuff
some merch mythical dot store is where
you can get all types of stuff big and
small here's a small thing a pop socket
that says it's got the mythical logo on
it I got a company that has the good
mythical morning logo on it so if you
want a little something like a mid
mid-year stocking stuffer like it get
the jump on stuffing that stuffing that
stocking and mythical ducks sure you'll
forget that it was in there you're like
wow I've already fill it up wasn't that
satisfying sound little pop sock it
makes fill it halfway up
we got stickers we got we got all types
of stuff rip your boys that's okay we
didn't need that anyway sorry anything
else you want to promote we got a store
on the Amazon - you can check that out
it's got different types of t-shirts all
types of stuff happening yeah okay I I
think our Spring Break vacations were
like polar opposite because I I did
something that I'm not used to doing and
then this will play out me not being
used to this over the course of the
specifics of my story but we didn't go
on what I call a vacation we went on a
sightseeing trip of London Lily had the
choice she wanted to go to London
I think predominantly because she's a
Harry Potter fan
and then I just think she's a fan of
like British programming I mean she went
through a Doctor Who phase and like the
sherlock benedict cumberbatch type
situation so I can't fault her for for
liking that British comedic Sensibility
and storytelling panache so I was like
I'm you know I missed the whole Harry
Potter boat but I don't even maybe there
isn't isn't a boat I don't know
a fireboat well I think there's a story
they don't have many boats in Harry
Potter I like a broomsticks you gotta
have a boat for something just brass
tacks and a train trains and sticks not
boats but I'm like you know what this is
for you this is what okay I we we knew
she was gonna choose in London I
basically booked the trip I got the air
B&B and listen Grove which is an area of
London is pretty centrally located close
to the tube
listen Grove Li sson and you know so a
nice little air B&B a little little bed
for her and then another bedroom for me
and Christie and a full kitchen all this
type of vibe you know we so we got our
own space but it's it was much more a
sightseeing trip than a vacation I think
though because there's no relaxing it's
not what are we gonna do next and what
are we going to see next we have booked
going to the Warner Brothers Studio Tour
where they filmed all the Harry Potter
movies and they have all the actual
props and costumes set pieces and all
types of things from from all of the
movies so we booked that ahead of time
on another day we also booked tickets to
the stage play from the world of harry
potter called cursed child which i
remember a couple of years back she
bought the we bought it of the script I
was like okay there's no other Harry
Potter book no it's just the script so
we got our hands on tickets for that
there's a two hour show and then there's
a bread
I mean there's an intermission in the
middle of that and then you come back
later and there's two basically two more
hours so it's two different plays it's a
lot of play but it's one story so you
got to you got to kind of go all-in if
it was about like two hours too much
play for me I was nervous
maybe 2.5 hours too much I mean I may
come back to it but I will say that
having done everything that I can list
out that we did it it was a highlight
like I really enjoyed it's one of my
favorite days was when we did that we
did we saw the first the first play
first two hours and then we took a break
walked around we went we went to do
Shoom the place that our favorite place
when we went to London very good I went
to a different one and it was just as
amazing I am actually calling it my
favorite restaurant now you're calling
it your favorite restaurant yeah I mean
it's better than Slug and Lettuce okay
yeah and then we went for the for the
other part of it and it was really well
done it wasn't a musical which I think
sidestep a bunch of potential you know
potholes so there's that much time
intermission such that you can eat a
dinner no there was an intermission in
the middle of the two-hour play and then
they were like you go out for two and a
half three hours then you come back and
watch another two-hour play right so
it's a it's a long break yeah the
intermission was just a 15-minute
bathroom break in the middle of each
play I got it
two-part story yes that I mean day three
was our studio tour day four was cursed
child so day one just to kind of rattle
off the things we did we'd like took the
tube to Westminster Abbey but it was a
Sunday so we couldn't get inside I
didn't realize that it started hailing
he was cold like literally though it was
the only day that I saw Sun the whole
time I was there it's like that is a
scarce commodity in London the solar
thing solar ball in this guy solar ball
in the sky the only day I saw it it was
also hailing on me so I had to adjust my
plan as
like going to Piccadilly Circus and we
we missed the changing of the guard got
hailed on I'm like man this is not a
good start on like our first full day
and then I was like it's too cold we
went it I was like we got to go into the
British Museum saw the rosetta stone
which that's pretty awesome
I didn't realize that look according to
what I read there at least maybe what
impair puffing themselves up too much
but if it wasn't for the rosetta stone
we would not know how to translate
Egyptian hieroglyphics
period we also would have those are
great infomercials late at night yeah
yeah which is why they exist right it's
there's three different languages on
there and then each language says that
hey this is written into other languages
says this is the same thing written in
three different languages so whichever
language you read you know that and
that's how they that's how they
deciphered hieroglyphics oh so I also
saw like one of the Easter Island dudes
they just got sitting in there the
British I was pretty cool the British
have had a tendency to just go places
and steal things and then bring them
back to their museums there's nothing
British in the British Museum I mean
there's like hunks of the Parthenon it
was awesome but it yeah you didn't get
this weird feeling and like III heard
people joking about it like you know
about how nothing near as is British and
I guess I mean I stole that joke which
wasn't that great I got this joke from
nothing there in the British Museum is
British we were there for like an hour
and then we ended up going we went on
the London Eye the big ferris wheel
Krissi didn't do that you know you're
developing a flavor profile of my wife
she doesn't like to fly but she did it
she conquered her fear there's a long
flight she conquered her fear every
single time she flies so Big Ups to
Christie but she did not elect to go on
the London Eye and I wasn't gonna you
choose your battles that wasn't it Chris
Lilley and I did that well we wouldn't
you talk about these things you need to
tell me you need to give me the I
recommend that or I don't recommend that
because I'm not I to be in London in
August and I you know I recommend the
British Museum I wouldn't do the top ten
audio tour because they kind of send you
around it every part of the museum and
that's what we did it was very cool so
we kind of got a whirlwind tour but I
would recommend that you look at the at
the types of things that you're
interested in and just choose one or two
and go there instead of trying to do the
top ten because there were things that I
weren't quite as interested in even
though just for the sake of them wanted
to take me around the whole museum if
you want a a good place to eat in
shortage we ended up that first night at
a place called Gloria which had amazing
pizza like really good pizza really good
vibe I think there's one in Paris and
then they just opened this one in London
and do you meet Gloria no but they had
records plane and like the ceiling was
mirrored it was it was it was really
cool and downstairs was awesome this
little is the Lenovo worth it or is it I
went in here worth it I went at night it
didn't feel worth it I I don't think
it's worth I can imagine yeah I can
imagine what it feels it looks like it's
very slow it's not you know it's not the
zipper it's missable not the Ring of
Fire and then on day 2 we get up I'm
like alright you know we got our oyster
card from the tube I'm like we got to
get back on the tube I think what
Christie didn't tell me was that but
part of the fear of flying is like the
companion
confined space type situation so she
wasn't really in love with the tube
either and you know I'm definitely not
criticising her because it's I mean
there's some there's some there's some
actual anxiety going on in there it's
like something that like I don't
experience so it's it's hard for me to
empathize and but I'm definitely not
gonna fall for the trap of making fun of
it then I will but something like all
right let's get back on the tube we're
gonna go to the Tower of London you know
we got the Harry Potter stuff just hold
out we'll get there tomorrow
let's just get this
let's get this tourist stuff out of the
way that everybody does and I'm kind of
stressing out because I'm like he's
taking me to different stops and like
the Google Maps are really good at
showing you which one to get on but like
then the Train it says it's about to
pull up and it says something a little
bit different I'm like I think this is
it let's get on and then you get on and
then you're like I'm like starting to
panic and I'm like this is not the right
one and I'm like it's not the right one
and it stopped it at the first stop and
I'm like get off we got to get off we
got to get off and we were still like
above ground at another platform though
and I'm like this isn't I looked at the
map where we were then I was like yeah
we we went the wrong direction and now
it's saying we got to go and we can't
just get on another train here and I'm
like in full panic mode I am I was I
actually was like falling apart and I
didn't realize it like I was panicking
and I'm like we've we've got to get you
know because getting on a train and then
like making a split decision to get off
and make sure that like all members of
your family are there I'm glad I didn't
have the boys with me I guarantee at
least one of them would have still be on
that tube right now so we're on the
platform good experience and like
Christie is like I think I'm like we
listen we got a we got to get on this we
got to go down here we got to go home in
this platform we got to get on another
train and we're going to totally
different direction now because we we
we're gonna be late and like she's like
why don't we just you know go up these
stairs and we could just Oh BRR and I'm
like no okay how we can't over I've got
this card I've invested in an oyster
card and I'm like I'm not yelling at
Christie I'm yelling at London okay okay
yeah I'm yelling at myself I think is
what was happening I was just freaking
out now I was like no way we have to we
can do this and like I can do this I can
I can I can navigate
I can get us there anyway what was your
daughter doing in this and she was like
she was trying to be helpful she was
looking on her phone and trying to
figure out which train to get on because
apparently this is very important to me
and I said what
we can't take it over you know I I'm
just and I'm looking at the phone and
like I'm trying to figure it out and
she's suggesting an alternate plan and
I'm like I I'm gonna throw this phone
onto the tracks and I like at that point
I locked eyes with Christie and I could
tell that like she could see that
something was wrong snapping inside of
me and it was just like then she was
like quiet I looked at Lilly and she
like licking her eyes she was like quiet
and I was like it was it was interesting
how and then we we get to the terilyn
and I'm thinking like man we got I was
like I'm trying to explain myself and
like listen it said it was gonna be a 20
minutes subway ride or they don't use
the word subway and or that's your
problem 30 minute call it at the
boomerang and it was you know we don't
have bought these and like the price and
all this stuff and it's like all this
stuff that doesn't matter I was just
trying to make myself I was trying to
explain myself and try to restore what I
felt like was the hope that was lost in
my girls eyes then I could lead us to
the Tower of London the place where
Queens were beheaded or whatever
did you adult in heaven did you know
they beheaded Grandma's ABI took the to
her brother they beheaded Queens oh yeah
King and a king's mom did you uh did you
make it on time did you miss your tour
well a tour leaves every 30 minutes okay
so again it's like it was I was freaking
out over nothing but it was like it was
a bad override there I will say that
like it was a day - yeah morning of day
two can't have this kind of can't break
you can't fall apart on date like we get
out of the Oberer and Chris is like
we're just gonna go get a coffee I'm
like well I'm gonna go get the tickets
and I'm like I had some space and I like
right you know I just needed a couple of
minutes to realize that I was
well you know falling apart on day two
actually there's a different way to see
that get it out of the way as long as
you don't fall that you don't fall out
you know you can break out again it was
a you know we we did the tour the tour
was fun
we saw the crown jewels in her rack I
always thought that those were testicles
yeah they're not you know what do you
think the rack is I thought those were
breasts crown jewels are you know for
it's not the Kings nuts its Kings jewels
it's literally jewels Rhett it's not a
euphemism for anything oh you dirty I
know I just
yeah oh there's a family jewels the
family jewels
yeah the crown jewels go in the crown
yeah and there's all these different
crowns and scepters and I kind of I
wasn't that into it but but you get on I
don't like gems not only Jim's I don't
like crowns and only acceptors well and
there's a bunch of them and you like get
on a moving platform and walk gotta take
your birthday present by standing you
stand and beat you're like escalated
down past him but then you go to like
where they would torture people and they
had a rack in there and I'm like this
was down in like the castle barracks
part I'm like man this is visceral this
is where it's at
there was one where they would you would
picture if you get down on your knees
and you're so your shins are on the
ground and then you put your belly on
top of your thighs and you like fold
your whole self over like you're in the
fetal position but on your shins sounds
awesome and then they put a rack over
top of you that fits over the top of
your back in and it comes together like
this and then that part starts wrenching
down and they just start wrenching you
down like scrunching you down on
yourself so it's the opposite of a rack
which like you know pulls you apart
pulls your all your joints apart and
they did this to people both of these
I've been to the torture museum in
Prague oh gosh I mean I saw two
apparatus like mini I I'm not into that
man I mean I was into two but I couldn't
be in two three I liked seeing
I like seeing the the you know the links
that human depravity can get to not
because I'm interested in it for myself
but because it's just to remind yourself
at how screwed up people are well if you
would have seen me on that platform
saying I'm gonna throw my phone onto the
tracks like when we got back into the
car after the tour one in which I you
know we had a good time like the
beefeaters take you on the tour and
they're like very boisterous and the
funny and so I was like okay this could
be behind us the rest of our day could
be you know we got into another uber and
it was like it was hard to find hard to
get into and it we weren't going back on
the tube and then we were over into
Camden Market and it was like we
couldn't couldn't meet up with the uber
and like I'm I'm starting to wig out
again and I realized that like I had all
these expectations that you know we were
gonna see all these things and
everything was gonna go perfectly and
everything was gonna go smoothly and it
was up to me like Christy and Lilly they
didn't they never put that on me I'll
put that on myself but you know I'm just
I have this perfectionistic way of
thinking that like was very
self-destructive in that moment and so
when we were back in the uber I still
couldn't I it was like I was back in
that place again after the the tour and
like it was quiet and think Chrissy was
but she like broke the ice and I was
like I was trying to explain myself
again and I was just like I thought I
was going to have a second breakdown
it was just like but I at this time
because I realized that I was carrying
that all this unnecessary weight of a
perfect successful trip being on my
shoulders that no one place there except
myself so once I got over that Camden
Market was awesome because it was some
really good food like you would love it
there you should go there there's like a
bunch of different food trucks and like
all different combinations of foods but
that was my first moment of
introspection and I think it's good to
have a couple which I did have a second
one but I'll tell you about after
hearing about a little bout Colorado but
I made it through that
well I embarrass myself as well oh good
oh yeah I'm going to tell you a little
story that will you'll see the purpose
in it it's a little back story okay so
as I established weeks ago I took the
very douche bag --is-- step of getting
custom ski boots made for myself you
told us all about those boots and you
know I have an unusually shaped foot
it's narrow it's long it's a high arch
there's the ski boots that you just get
to the rental place they just you know
they can't handle my feet your arch is
so high it looks like it was put in one
of those torture devices yeah it might
have been which I think women call a
high heel I don't remember my early
childhood like your foot bent over on
itself so I I had these boots made and
then when I went to Mammoth the trip
that I talked about before I actually
ended up with a quite a bit of pain in
my heels like the sides of my heels and
specifically the right foot was very
painful the outside of the right foot
okay so I go back to the place in Studio
City ski net sports IFRIC I didn't know
the name last time a shout out to Claude
ski net sports he'll hook you up Willie
yeah well yeah because here's what he
does
you can never guarantee if a boots gonna
have a perfect fit to go out and play
around in it you know ski in it as they
say and I I go back and I tell him I
show him on my feet where it's hurting
and then he takes this makeup he takes
my socks he says take your socks off he
doesn't do that for you and then he puts
makeup on your feet and you put them
back in the boots and then he has you
pushed your foot back into the back of
the boot and then it's basically you've
pointed to where it hurts he's put
makeup on there and then it shows inside
the boot exactly where that spot is
hurting and it turns out you've got like
a little he showed me a like a diagram
of a of a skeleton of the bones of the
foot and there's this little foot
there's this little bone on the outside
of your heel that juts out and for a lot
of
people that can be painful and so he
goes it takes the boot I thought he's
gonna like melt the boot and like move
it around but he actually just took a
little sander thing and went in and like
ground dremel yeah he ground it down I
could have done that and created a
pocket for that bone on both feet this
is this is great so I'm like so ready to
ski as I'm leaving I'm like you're
supposed to rain and Vail he said well
you know what that means like what he
said it won't because he was like the
weather forecast always changes right
before you get there he said but just in
case take a couple of these and he gives
me this little it's like a ring that
looks like a little flipper like a foot
flipper but he said it's a little
windshield wiper for you if it rains to
wipe the rain off of your goggles you
got a a finger yeah
when shall I he's like one for you and
one for the lady and I was like well I
didn't tell him my wife wasn't gonna ski
but I was like I'll take both of them
whatever okay so so Jessi was not gonna
ski Jessi was like she's I'm gonna read
I'm gonna go around and hang out in
coffee shop so I'm gonna eat whatever
I'm having a great time okay and but me
and Locke and Shepard were going to ski
the whole time like we were there for
seven days we were gonna ski for six
really one day off first day it had
snowed a bunch the week before but it
was perfectly sunny Claude was right the
forecast changed no rain in the forecast
except for till the last day basically a
week of Sun okay you haven't skied in
Colorado alright now you you you've done
Park City which is an incredible resort
so you've kind of experienced that but
it was also there was like a blizzard
when we skied to ski in Colorado on a
bit they have an into one of the best
years I've ever had in vailed it's like
a 400 inch base and it's sunny
moving away from me Hale he's not in the
mood for a close-up missed opportunity
buddy
he was absolutely incredible I mean they
were there were moments where I was just
like I don't do like the crazy double
black diamonds or anything you know I'm
like a blue man the Blue Man Group and I
just kind of take you like me easy
things into percussion yeah and I just
kind of keep it easy and I just carve
and I like to get not too fast cuz I
don't want to hurt myself yeah just have
a great time this is not an airport and
I'm I mean I'm having so much fun in
there it's so expansive what about you
know an hour and a half into skiing my
heel starts hurting I'm like man Claude
I had a feeling that Claude had not
quite gotten come on Claude van he could
not quite dremeled out enough of that
you know I could have made a bigger hole
from a big old bone but he didn't and so
I'm hurting a little bit but you know
I'm like you know what you know maybe
you got to break him in a little bit
maybe that's what you got to do maybe
you got to break the boots in a little
bit once they get adjusted well lunch
rolls around and we've decided to meet
Jesse at a restaurant because one of the
I mean first of all I highly recommend
Vail I'll tell you the only reason I
don't recommend Vail and I'll get into a
story later that illustrates this it's
too expensive it's just they have you
trapped there they charge you too much
for everything but it's beautiful and
the village basically it's a you ski
right down to the village and you just
like put your skis up and then you just
walk to a restaurant meet your wife who
doesn't have skis I can walk in your ski
boots well I can't because they're
custom no anybody can walk in their ski
boots I mean it's awkward but yeah yeah
but but Claude told me he said you keep
these strapped down the whole day you
don't have to you know with rental boots
a lot of times you have to let him loose
before I should walk around he said
these ship it's so tight and so
perfectly you just keep them down the
whole day so I'm trying to do that you
know I want to be a purist I'm gonna do
what the guy tells me to do but as I
walk into the rest of them like my foot
is hurting my heel is hurting me maybe
maybe dare I say worse than it did the
first time before he made any
adjustments okay
and I sit down we have lunch at this
restaurant I I have to take my boot off
because it's hurting so bad hmm
take it off now is that admitting defeat
did you feel like less of a man at that
point I was like this is your version of
taking the uber at this point I was like
I'm gonna have to call calling we have
to tell him he didn't get it he didn't
get it right I'm gonna have to rent
boots for the rest of the week
nullifying my whole purchase you were
gonna call him and say screw you no no I
was gonna call him and say dude I got to
get these adjusted when I get back cuz
it didn't work okay
but I put it back on I said I'm gonna
ski the rest of the afternoon and get
back out there
awesome I took it off you didn't see
anything wrong with it I'm never gonna
say he left a dremel in there no I take
it off nothing I mean I take it off and
my foot instantly feels better I put it
back in there Mike okay yeah this is
good I'll get let me get it tight maybe
it's just I need maybe it just needs to
be tighter because he told me he's gotta
be tight you got a good testing chart in
there cuz I got it perfect and so I can
get it super tight we ski a little bit
more I'm having the time of my life let
me just tell you I took a little pain
reliever just to preemptively deal with
the pain yeah yeah but we get down we've
got a ski across the mountain to get
back to where we were staying it's kind
of the slopes closed pretty early
they're around four o'clock and so we
were gonna like come about 3:30 and come
into the chart you literally I mean talk
about being a douche I mean you ski
directly down the hill and you ski to
the valet guy for your hotel and you
just give him your skis and you walk and
he has hot chocolate and then you walk
into your hotel yeah I mean it's all
right there it's unbelievable it's the
douchiest thing you could possibly
imagine
and there's douches everywhere
everywhere everywhere everywhere douche
it's like looking in a mirror I mean
people who ski in Vail this is a douchey
as it gets man as far as four I've ever
been around
yeah yeah you loving it and so I I we're
skiing back to in this big mountain so
we've got a lot of skiing as you and I
get to a place where I'm like my foot is
hurting me so bad
I
I can't show I can't reveal how much
pain I'm into my boys I got it I got a
betta dad I got a I got a hold this in
yeah but there's a couple of times where
we stopped where I would have to stop
and like wait on Shepherd cuz he was
still kind of getting his legs and I
would stop and it would the pain would
just like shoot from my heel all the way
up my leg and I would go oh like it
would be a moment Oh like crying out
like that and then as your eyes crossed
and then I started thinking I mean I may
start crying I'm in so much pain like I
hadn't cried from pain since I was a
child really but like my eyes were what
I was like oh and then lot was like dad
do we need we need to get help and I'm
like no son your dad's gonna make it to
the bottom of the mountain your dad is a
super douche his super tight fitted
custom boots which don't amount a mount
amount of crap
your dad will not be out douched by any
of the other douches around here your
dad is the douchiest dad he's gonna cry
he's gonna kid he's gonna keep skiing
all the way to his valet and with that
he's gonna grab that hot chocolate tears
in his eyes in his eyes so and he's
gonna retrieve his testicles kept down
at the base of the mountain I make it to
the bottom of the mountain and I'm in
intense pain I get my hot chocolate
which makes me feel a little bit better
I walk back to my room I my wife is
still out and about doing whatever she
wants I take off my boot and that link
is when I don't know your story I did
not know I didn't realize it before but
the little windshield wiper that he had
given me was in the bottom and I had
even even when I said like no I thought
that uranium for something at the
restaurant this was in the bottom of my
boot my gosh and let me show you what my
foot look like it was okay you paid so
much money for custom fitted boots and
then you put a you put a plastic
windshield wiper directly under your
heel now you may think to yourself how
could how could you not feel that there
was something under it yeah and
something about the shape of this the
fact that it was perfectly situated in
the bottom of my heel the fact that it
has absolutely no edge on one side and
then it is a perfect circle and the fact
that I had experience almost the exact
same type of pain before all these
factors led me to never consider that
maybe the freaking ski gee they call it
that's funny squeegee ski G is the thing
that was sending so much pain into my
body and it's weird how like it was
literally sending it directly up your
heel it was crazy I think that's like a
an acupuncture type situation like in
the fact that I made the decision early
on to be like you know what it needs to
be tighter like that was when you
ratcheted it down let me tell you the
rest of the trip when I didn't have that
thing in my boot Clawd shoutout to you
brother
you made my feet feel incredible I mean
you shouldn't have given me that ski G
because I put it in my boot that was my
fault but the repairs you made to my
boots were on point I don't need any
adjustments I'm so happy this Adu shiest
boots I've ever had this is one happy
douche but and so that was day one that
was day one I'm glad I got that out of
the way
wow what if what if you two realized it
at the end of the trip well it would
have been difficult to do because I did
look in my boot you know I didn't look
at it in the restaurant because I kind
of I didn't even want to draw attention
to you taking food off you were too
concerned about your rep you want all
the other douches to know that you
nobody else on the restaurant had their
boots on at all nobody was even anyway I
had the skiing
ended up being an incredible part of the
trip I did yell at my children a little
bit just to kind of join the club it's
interesting that you're I mean you're
the one who likes variety and don't like
to go back and do the same thing like I
thought you mean like man I got this
skiing thing is getting old I want to
experience something different
well like are you doubling down on the
skiing now no at the end of the
my conclusion and I'd like to have a
feeling and to sort of distill a feeling
at the end of the trip yeah and then
kind of like remember that because
you'll forget about it it's just like
when you have a child after you have a
child you're like I'm never doing that
again and then you wears off and you
have more kids yeah you didn't distill
it enough you got to distill it
distilled at the end of the vacation I
was like that was super fun but a couple
of things I feel like I narrowly avoided
getting seriously hurt like just
statistically speaking there was so much
skiing involved for me and my two sons
that the fact that none of us got hurt I
kind of feel like we got lucky because
there was people getting on our plane in
wheelchairs and they were like had been
recently injured Wow during their time
in Vail and also yeah you do kind of
feel like I've kind of been down this
trail I and because I'm not some super
risk-taker and I don't like jump off of
cliffs my skiing experience sort of
maxes out with a certain thing and so
and also Jesse didn't do it with us and
so I kind of felt like I wasn't really
spending that much time with her so I
thought you know what so you're saying
this phase is coming to an end no no no
I think that the weekend ski trip the
2-day the three-day ski trip but a full
week of skiing in one place we're not
gonna do it next year we're gonna do
something else and then we'll decide as
a family if we want to go back and do it
again I had an incredible time and the
kids one of the things about doing that
much skiing back-to-back is like the
learning curve like the kids are so much
better like we were like Shepherd like
can keep up with with us perfectly now
because it just did so much scheme well
you know I agree that you should distill
down your trip I think for me as it
relates to the trip you know but I had
all the expectations of what the perfect
trip would look like from an itinerary
standpoint on the fifth day we went to
Stonehenge and bath and then just to
give you a complete view of what my trip
was I do recommend going to Stonehenge I
know you're into it's not wood but
you're also in rocks and you're in the
lengths five thousand-year-old
Rock configurations very cool
is okay
[Music]
tastes like bad pipes it was cool to
walk around but I really loved
Stonehenge but as as far as like
distilling it down I also think I had a
lot of expectations I got really excited
the months back when I said this is
gonna be like sweet 16 lily trip it's
good you know I I don't know what I
pictured specifically but I will be
honest and this is not a criticism of of
Lily in any way I think it's it's more
of just my internal dialogue that I
don't know I I felt like there was gonna
be some magical sweet 16 moment that I
thought myself questioning should I have
done something more ceremonial like when
we went to bath and we it's bath is the
only naturally occurring hot springs in
the UK in that one town and they built a
whole you know like town around it you'd
like people come for for forever and
just drink from the springs and they
started bathing in it you know it's like
maybe I should do some sort of sweet 16
ceremony here so I'm sure that wasn't
well yeah yeah it's like you know that
was not my instinct at the time but then
when it was done we're coming back I was
like was it could it could it have been
even more special you know I think I was
thinking I don't know that they would
all of a sudden our in the the the
structure or like the tone of our entire
relationship would shift like I I in in
I alternate Lee talked it up to me
having these nebulous but huge and
unrooted expectations of some magical
event happening where oh look my
daughter is a woman now and I guess
that's not the right wait is it but like
it was that we'd have this special
moment like they were remember that one
moment when she turned to me and her mom
and said you know what you're the
greatest parents on earth and
I am so I just feel like I'm having them
the most special moment of my life right
now and I'm glad that I'm sharing it
with you and not with some two-bit
boyfriend who wants to take me to some
knockoff prom situation knockoff bro I
don't know I'm just as that there is no
there is no two-bit boyfriend and
there's no knockoff prom I'm just saying
like you know as your as your kids get
older at least for me I want to know
that like I have a vibrant and special
relationship as it evolves because make
no mistake it is evolving I mean she's
becoming an adult so it's not a
parent-child relationship exclusively
now it's like there's a there's a friend
component they're starting to have
conversations that you would have with
any other adult and seeing her rise to
that occasion conversationally and say
oh yeah she's I'm seeing my daughter
differently as a more mature person
who's becoming her own complete adult
you know that's really starting to
happen at this point in an emotional
relational level but I apparently had
some sort of expectation that there will
be a magical moment that only happens in
the movies man and that happens on
television and if you that is it
happening and to your point if you tried
to like ceremonial eyes it it could go
very sideways it could be very awkward
it you can't so I kind of swung the
pendulum recommen that if I would have
tried to create some sort of ceremonial
moment like manufactured or engineer it
that the chances of that backfiring into
awkwardness and just see me forced
there's a high likelihood of that so I
think my takeaway it having been a while
since the trip is just an appreciation
that we did the trip I think as more
time passes it will actually grow to be
even more special that's my theory at
least that you take the whole time
as a whole and it it's not you know the
picture that we took in front of
Westminster Abbey when it started
hailing honest maybe that'll be a great
memory - I think it will be but it's
coming back after going to the Harry
Potter tour all day and riding in some
huge freaking torturous bus for like a
net over an hour to get to this place
and to come back and then just crashing
that hour at our room and saying you
know what let's just watch something and
she's like let's watch the umbrella
Leslie what's it called Umbrella Academy
this is like series on on Netflix that
she's into she's like I've already
watched it but I want to watch it with
you guys so it's like all three of us
piling into our bed and watching a
Netflix series together and I think
those are the things that I'm gonna
remember it's like we hung out like
friends and it was it was special and
even yeah they may remember me having
the breakdown or they you know and I
think we'll be able to laugh about those
type of things but I think it's it's an
investment it's an investment in setting
an environment where we can have an
experience together so that the weird
the frustrating the tired the end the
special all kind of meld together and
create something that I believe is
unforgettable
but doesn't translate into something you
can just buy in a souvenir shop and
remember it's not like something it's
like it's like investing into your
retirement fund and then like going back
the next day and like looking at it like
oh oh
when is this when is this gonna grow I
think that's right because I mean and
also think from her from her perspective
it's not like I expected her to
articulate things that a 16 year old she
hasn't a point of reference that's like
you know I didn't want to go into this
lecture mode but not every
sixteen-year-old gets to go anywhere
they won't in the world and you get to
go to London and like don't forget what
we've done for you it's like I actually
I was tempted to go in and out a few
times like I should do that from from
time to time just to be a good dad not
that she wasn't grateful or
appreciative because she was but you
just have to hope that when the kids
write the tell-all book uh-huh that the
good outweighs the bad man and the best
you can hope for is that you're gonna
get like a card like okay realistically
you're gonna get like a card when
they're 33 okay and they've got some
life experience and then they're like
they write you a really sweet card and
they're like I remember that trip and
I've really thought about how you cared
about us and the time that you put into
our relationship but you're not gonna
unless you've got an exceptionally
exceptional unusual expressive child
they're not gonna be like I want to let
you know that this vacation is going
incredibly well and I recognize right
that you guys have actually thought
about this in a way that you know this
is just I realize this is just for me
like you guys made a decision to believe
the other kids at home to just bring me
here to do the things that I wanted to
do to create a memory for me
that would you guys are the best parents
in the world yeah that's what I want it
and that would be weird wouldn't it you
know what you don't want that because
then it's about you mmm it's not true
it's not about you it's about the
investment that you're making in your
daughter and your family and then you
got to hope that not only is it first of
all you don't do it just for the card or
for the tell-all book to be good versus
bad you're doing it because you actually
think is contributing to her as a person
and how can she know how could she even
process like I can at my age I can
barely process the the way that the my
experiences are impacting Who I am no I
mean I deal with the same things with my
kids it was like I mean I know I do on a
regular basis and also think that the
generalization here but dealing with two
boys is a little bit it's a little bit
different and I
they're like constantly fighting and
like constantly annoying each other and
we had to like there were multiple times
where I'm just like going to that kind
of dad mode you know yeah and then have
to pull myself back but you know you
talk about you guys getting together one
of the most special things that we
experienced on our trip was okay so
every day the three of us would go out
and ski there would be multiple fights
between Locke and Shepherd because likes
getting mad that Shepherds holding them
up holding us up and he's you know he
falls down and then he needs help and
other people have to help him if I'm
below him on the mountain and stop and
then Locke would be like I'm gonna scoop
up myself and so he goes off and does
his teenage ski by himself thing and
then Shepard and I ski and then we'll
meet up again
[Applause]
[Applause]
you better do that you gonna come down
that so that kind of thing is happening
I'm kind of trying to manage it and I'm
not trying to force it because I want
the same thing I want there to be these
moments of like a father and his two
sons and perfect rhythm on the slopes of
Colorado yeah postcard yeah but really
it and what other skiing they're looking
at you talking about how great of a dad
you are yeah right
but really the what's happening is I'm
getting separated from Shepherd and I'm
getting a phone call from Jesse who got
a phone call from the guy at the lift
who's like your son is here and his lost
that happened yes not it worth a
Shepherd or a lot the Shepherd lock had
his own phone but Shepherd was fine he
didn't panic or anything he knew that he
would get in touch when we got we got
like took backup and also in the midst
of looking for Shepherd cutting off this
little girl in her dad comes skiing got
to me and he's like what the hell are
you thinking and me not saying anything
back to him because I didn't have an
answer now something to my vote no that
was after the boot had been there was
some boot yesterday but the cool one of
the best things that happened as a
family is we would go skiing and then we
would come back and we would go out to
eat and then we would come back to the
hotel and they had their room and we had
our room but we would all get into our
bed so four of us which is even more
difficult than three people in a bit and
we would watch the Goldbergs now I know
I but I have told you I've already
plugged the Goldbergs once but you we
plug in some gold burners that was your
show and again all right let me just say
that I'm not saying that it's a perfect
show I'm saying it is the perfect show
to watch as our family because we all
fit these totally exaggerated tropes on
the show is so exaggerated we're not
really I mean it's you don't have to go
back through while the Goldbergs is
great but know what we do for you know
but like we relate there's something
about all this stuff that we've done
during the day of like lock being the
typical teenager and shepherd being the
typical annoying little brother and
jesse being the
overprotective mom and me being the dad
were the short fuse that when you sit
down and you see it played out comedic
ly in a show it just we start realizing
how we've just fallen into these roles
in these predictable ways and it just
makes us we bonded as a family and then
which is like Shepherd it would be like
10 o'clock at night and I would share
Birds figured out how to call room to
room of course so we started doing that
a lot the phone ring I pick it up and be
like hello and she would be like you
know what time it is I was like why is
it Goldberg time he was like he was so
into us sitting down and there's no kind
of like our survivor time and there's
yeah there's not a like you've said
before there's not a lot of there's not
a lot of entertainment out there that
you can just sit down as a family and
just completely bond that used to be the
way it was yeah ironically back in the
80s which is when the Kohlberg's is base
but that was a sweetest time that we had
like lots of typical family stuff that
we did of getting on each other's nerves
but there was that time we could all get
together all file into the bed and just
I think that that's the kind of thing
that they're going to remember it yeah
they're gonna they're gonna have a
memory of like I remember being that you
don't remember being annoyed by your
little brother or your big brother or
your your dad having a short fuse or
your mom getting you know picking it
something on you and getting upsetting
you I think you remember those the sweet
times and if they don't we can make them
listen to this podcast do you have
anything else from London no that's it
man we ride we rode the double-decker
bus Christie like that a lot better than
the tube a lot more visibility everybody
was happy what's up
once we've got up top of the
double-decker bus I have a quick wreck
and that I think you're gonna be you're
gonna hold hard to choke baby one two
three four check baby to baby one two
just as a small addendum because I can't
not tell you this in the little shop in
Vail there's a rattle a little this is
the rat I'm teasing the wreck okay
in the little shop in Vail in Vail
Village well in Vail Valley there's a
bunch of shops and there's a bunch of
like really like rich folk
stuff like all those boutiques and we
went into this one store called Gorsuch
which I just thought that he was the guy
that Obama tried to get to be the Samuel
Court nominee and didn't work out too
well but apparently it's a brand or it's
a store and you could kind of tell from
the window that this was like doosh
central it's release your you were like
a moth to a flame well here's the thing
I'll get custom ski boots but I don't go
in and buy unnecessarily expensive
clothing I I don't I don't like the vest
with like skiers on I don't do that
so we go into this place you went in for
entertainment purposes I'm not gonna buy
anything I'm going in there because I'm
blown away at the culture and like the
vibe and it's three stories
I think the collars won't unpop there we
go in there and if you walk in the first
level is the women's level okay and
there was this coat that was like a like
a like a cardigan of some kind but a
little bit longer I think that's just a
coat
nothing special looks like something
from the rack of forever 21 okay price
tag two thousand dollars three thousand
nine hundred and ninety eight dollars
four thousand dollars and I was like
what and I was like I'm gonna be in here
a while because this is so entertaining
to me to there's people actually
shopping and trying things on I go
upstairs to the men's section and that
was when and I'd already kind of picked
up on this there's a bunch of Italian
people lots of people from Europe lots
meals people speaking Spanish and
Italian okay but lots of Italian people
who apparently have lots on e
discretionary cash getting that Italian
leather and this dude is trying on this
puffy jacket in front of his girlfriend
how do I look good but he said in
Italian and she was like do you knew
that somebody was saying she was like
Bonjour
Bonita well I don't know what French
what is the I don't know she said it
looked good and then I went and I picked
one up oh you kind of on the slide
looked it too
thousand dollars it was just a puffy
jacket this dude was about to buy it I
mean this point is your future but
here's the man all right so you're
saying you would never do this
cuz you're on a slippery note of your
hot chocolate well ho no first of all
I'd ski boots cause what ski boots costs
right okay
in the long run I'm actually gonna save
money because you have to rent them
every time you go okay but the thing I
told Jesse is I was like I don't you
know me I'm a tightwad man I'm like I
bought the Oyster card he's got $5.00 on
it I can't uber well but but no but
let's just say you had unlimited money
like if money was not an object which is
the same which I never understood what
exactly that means literally but money
is no obstacle to you right yeah you
wouldn't buy that if I had all the money
in the world I would not buy a $4,000
jacket if it did some PD doesn't do
anything it did something very special
like told the future then you'd probably
buy it but I mean you're not just gonna
buy one it done tell the future
but apparently this stuff is so
expensive that Americans can't even buy
it you got to be Italian oh you got to
be rich and from another country you
know what I'm saying like cuz I was the
only American that ventured into this
particular show maybe two maybe the
dollar conversion is confusing and
there's and there's something about
Italians doing it that makes it seem not
douchey they can do anything you know
I'm saying it's like he's kind of making
himself seem humble in that two thousand
two thousand dollar jacket and I can
never get away with that every time they
get in the car they're magically driving
on an undulating highway on the coast
right like that's how Italians roll I
don't understand where the money came
from a road
it's like Italian royalty but that's not
a thing cuz it's not a monarchy I don't
know where it comes from
pasta money that's what it is they just
they just churn it out like pasta yeah
they just extrude money sail a boat I
shut out to the non douchey very rich
Italians of Vail may your four thousand
dollar jackets keep you warm at night
what's your recommendation man uh my
recommendation is a song that actually
you played for me I do want to say
quickly that I've made a recommendation
a musical recommendation
that we had to cut out because the
person I recommended said something
problematic so I'm not and I already
said that on Twitter not cardi B no it
wasn't cardi B it was it was a lesser
very lesser-known so Michael did it no
now you're just saying things it was
somebody that you probably didn't know
about controversial artists no I'm
saying that me mentioning them too like
90% of you would be your first time
you'd ever heard this person's name and
then you'd look them up and you'd see
the thing there in the news for now is
something problematic so you're about to
what we took the wreck out you're about
to make the same mistake again no I'm
giving you like a very non problematic
music don't wreck the same guy this is
not a guy this is a group and this is a
group that my son and I bonded over
because I played this particular song
and I feel like I opened up a world to
my son and he actually ended up texting
me today about this whole movement of
music that we talked about and that is
make it with you buy bread which i think
is a is love this i think is a is on the
post concert playlist yeah that you put
together yeah i've been big on this song
for a while cuz no matter of fact that
played spot if i played it in the car
the other day and lily was like you
played this song a lot so she didn't
seem to love bread okay well my boys in
it and so make it with you buy bread
bread is this soft rock band that i
think that songs for like 73 or 74 but
early seventies almost as a hey
rebellion ever tried really reaching out
for the other side as a rebellion
against the the sort of the disco
movement that was happening these guys
were doing something they were just
pouring out their music like syrup well
they were climbing on rainbows it was
absolutely amazing in this song dare i
say there are no perfect songs but if
you had to put songs into closest to
perfect as it can possibly be make it
with you by bread is a as close to
perfect song as there is oh man that's a
strong words i think it and listen to it
with your air phones
oh your biscuits it's like summer breeze
but a little less douchey so it's not
like it's
like the Italian summer breeze is like
the Italian summer breeze yeah I agree
with that it's like putting on a $4,000
jacket and realizing that oh I didn't
even pay for this all right guys we're
gonna we're gonna wrap this up thanks
for going with us on a journey back
through our experiences over spring
break vote for us for the webby if you
want to leave a or leaver if it's past
that and you're listening to this in the
distant future you can still leave a
review on iTunes if that still happens
that still exists in the future how far
in the future you listening to this no
I'm glad I'm glad you're still in the
ether somebody's listening this in 2031
our great-grandchildren 2031 tonight
hopefully we will have
great-grandchildren by then well I mean
you might be biologically possible but
it would be controversial to say the
least that's like 12 years from now
that's a good point
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]